bindi Irwin opens up about having
anxiety after losing her father Steve he
was really he was living his
super-hearing bindi was just eight years
old when she lost her dad Crocodile
Hunter Steve Irwin in the new issue of
Australian Women's Weekly the Dancing
with the Stars champ reveals she
developed anxiety after her dad's death
fearing she could lose her mom or her
brother too she explained it was really
bad when I was younger now I just have
this sense that I want to protect them
the strongest person has been taken away
so what about everyone else the wildlife
conservationist credits her time on the
show with helping her heal it changed my
life because I was able to close those
chapters that I never really been able
to close before it really gave me an
opportunity to say okay I can be at
peace with it and I'm okay
these days the seventeen-year-old is
happy and in love she gushed over her
boyfriends wakeboard Pro Chandler Powell
telling the mag I think that's why I
love him so much because he gets my
world